word of a growing partnership between
police and the popular doorbell company
ring is raising privacy concerns
nationwide Amazon owned ring sells
low-cost home security systems ring said
yesterday more than 400 law enforcement
agencies use its neighborhood watch
program that gives police potential
access to customers videos Jamie yuccas
shows us how guarding your home could
compromise your privacy somebody is
there and they're breaking into my house
rings home surveillance cameras have
captured crooks in the act everything
from home break-ins to stolen packages
you can stay informed with alerts from
your community ring also offers the
neighbors app which lets customers know
when and where a crime happens in their
area it works in conjunction with the so
called neighbors portal now used by some
400 law enforcement agencies to request
customer video that might help their
investigations ring CEO Jamie Semenov my
goal would be to have every
law-enforcement agency
on the police portal it helps all
communities come together to make things
safer we're gonna see a growing sense of
people sort of becoming kind of
informants on our neighbors and our
neighborhoods Andrew Ferguson is author
of the rise of big data policing there's
obviously going to be potential problems
with who gets targeted in those
neighborhood apps and that can be very
troubling because what can happen of
course is that there could be a police
response and that could impact someone's
liberties someone's lives ring says its
customers have complete control over
their videos and can choose to give
consent to a law enforcement request for
access the ring customer will see a
request come up they can either accept
the request or they can opt out of that
request and all future requests and the
police will never see if they have done
that but privacy advocates worry that
customers might not always have the
final say yes we have a choice sometimes
but it's very easy for police to get a
search warrant for that same footage if
they believe a crime has occurred I can
tell you we'll always follow the laws
but we will always fight for our
customers rights their control and their
privacy you know
for CBS this morning Jamie yuccas Los
Angeles